clémence de villecourt donc vous
parcourez le grand ouest avec une
roulotte depuis 79 jours afin de
promouvoir l'histoire de l'aviation vous
faites actuellement une escale et tape à
bois d'arcy julie rocha soirée c'est
l'audi moins deux sont venus vous voir
d'ailleurs ce matin on regarde ce
reportage on se retrouve après pour plus
de détails
accueil chaleureux malgré une pluie
incessante clémence et sa roulotte
sillonnent le grand ouest depuis 79
jours et font état pourquoi dassault
jusqu'à mercredi soir un voyage sur le
thème de l'aviation pour fédérer les
enfants autour de l'amour de lire et
d'écrire et de les inviter à voyager à
travers l'histoire la géographie et puis
un siècle de progrès donc le meilleur
moyen c'est de les impliquer un voyage
est un voyage bac il découvre par
différents moyens notamment un blog et
par des parts d écriture auxquels ils
sont invités à participer
aujourd'hui trois classes rencontre
clémence et son univers magique devant
la grange de votre anglais est vide et
j'aimerais bien faire une aventure comme
la clémence où elle voyage sur les
petites routes avec des chevaux dans la
caverne d'ali baba des poèmes des
dessins des photos de grand aviateur des
ouvrages de référence et surtout le
grand livre du voyage et la malle aux
trésors
chacun a puis déposez une enveloppe
contenant son rêve c'est dé marcher sur
les nuages mercredi soir clémence et ses
trois juments qui tireront bois d'arcy
le fief de l'aviateur alberto santos
dumont
direction saint cyr l'école bucs orly
pour terminer l'épopée de 180 jours au
bourget
clémence de villecourt vient donc de
vous voir dans ce reportage avec
notamment le grand livre du voyage le
grand livre du voyage vous êtes venu
avec il est posé juste sur cette table
on va le feuilleter un petit peu tout à
l'heure mais déjà c'est une drôle d'idée
ce parcours en roulotte pourquoi l'idée
était vraiment de montrer une autre
manière d'aborder de livres et
l'écriture et cette manière et cette
autre manière doit être abordée sous la
forme douce et à dire l'invitation au
voyage voyage de connaissances voyage
des verts et d'émerveillement et le
cheval reste fédérateur il reste
également un animal qui émerveille et il
permet l'air de rien d' invités à
partager un voyage et des signes
impliqués l'idée double en fait c'est
revenir sur l'histoire de la conquête du
ciel par l'homme est aussi mettre en
avant les secteurs clés de l'innovation
transports environnement énergie
communication c'est ça qui a mené qui a
motivé ce projet la volonté c'est de
trouver un thème fédérateur qui nous
permettent de parler d'histoire de
géographie est également toujours est
dans l'air du temps
aujourd'hui la société manque de rêve
donc il faut les y emmener la société
heureusement l'économie aéronautique est
porteuse d'emplois et donc il y a à
travers notre démarche la volonté que
les uns et les autres puissent accéder à
des métiers notamment dans
l'aéronautique et il y a également une
volonté de est bien de leur faire voir
le monde sous une autre forme et
aujourd'hui se pose une question
essentielle est que doit résoudre que
vous commande va résoudre la jeunesse et
qu'elle transporte pour demain quelles
sont les innovations pour demain et le
monde aéronautique est toujours au coeur
de cette actualité et est toujours
capable d'y répondre pour encore
quelques images vous transporter cette
exposition de ville en ville depuis à
peu près 80 jours 79 jours pour être
pour être précis qu'est ce qu'on trouve
dans cette roulotte dans cette
exposition est vraiment c'est vrai que
c'est une caverne d'ali baba parce qu'on
y trouve la fameuse malle aux trésors
qui déborde de l'être actuellement c'est
un musée
également musée de l'histoire de
l'aviation avec tout un univers de
lettres d'affiche d'écriture de cartes
postales et c'est un vrai enchantement
et la roulotte
elle est dans l'esprit 1910-1920 je
voyage costumés et elle a toute une
atmosphère qui sans parasites
j'entends des parasites qui peuvent un
peu nous nuire aujourd'hui dans le monde
moderne tel que nous le vivons et
c'est un lieu apaisant un lieu de savoir
et de connaissance et la personne sur le
bord de la route quand on voit passer
avec la roulotte
ah oui c'est surprendre mais dans le bon
sens du terme barcelone quelques fois ah
oui on nous avons des idées vraiment des
encouragements permanents et il est vrai
que nous sommes entrés en ile de france
voici une dizaine de jours on a un peu
l'impression que c'était les visiteurs
qui arrivait mais c'est un petit peu
seul quand on s'est retrouvés sur des
départementales un peu transformée en
voie express est hélas c'était c'était
vraiment bon à vivre là vous avez
échangé avec des élèves de bois d'arcy
comment ça s'est passé quel bilan vous
en faites un échange on s'intéresse dès
lors que l'on dit oui à mes voyages
on va vivre quelque chose de très
surprenant d'autres qui va très loin
dans la qualité d écriture dans la
qualité de la transmission de ce voyage
est dans l'émotion que qui va naître
puisque les élèves notamment ceux de
bois d'arcy me suivent depuis le départ
donc ils m'ont vu avant que je parte en
voyage et je vise et invités à partager
ce voyage sous la forme de l'écriture et
en revenant sur toute l'histoire de
santos dumont
une histoire qu'il ne connaissait pas et
que la ville avait à un moment donné
peut-être aussi bine perdu 2 perdus de
vue
et là toute la ville et autour de santos
dumont la tradition parce que forcément
c'était aussi dans ce secteur de saint
cyr l'école l'aviation était très pressé
sans les nommer
donc là il ya donc l'émotion qui
ressenti forcément très forte dans la
mesure ils ont été impliqués depuis très
longtemps qui suivent le voyage depuis
le 10 mars où je suis parti ils suivent
à l'église épreuve du voyage les
connaissances qu'apporte ce voyage est
donc
et forcément quand je vais arriver avec
trois juments et une roulotte
ils ont cette attente qui chaque jour
les les invite à les découvrir à travers
mon blog et autres et c'est très fort
quand on est on est au coeur d'un voyage
les enseignants pleurs
les élèves chantent et une remède leurs
lettres donc on est vraiment voilà ça
marche pas alors c'est une malle aux
trésors on l'a aperçue à ce livre aussi
ce grand livre que nous avez vous avez
amené sur ce plateau qui posait juste
devant moi sur cette table je voulais
c'est l'ouvrir et puis nous expliquer
peut-être qu'on ce qu'on trouve à
l'intérieur
alors déjà évidemment c'est un grand
livre rare qui est fabriqué à toutes les
villes qui ont répondu favorablement à
notre demande et a été remis une grande
page de la cette facette pas j'ai
fabriqué par un des derniers pas petit
breton qui travaillent encore du lin
l'idée c'était de revenir sur l'histoire
des frères montgolfier
parce que les montgolfières envolée
cessantes c'était des c'était du papier
au départ donc chaque ville a une
feuille vierge et les élèves participent
à l'écriture de cette page sur le thème
ma ville et un lien avec l'aviation
alors par exemple celle de bois d'arcy
aujourd'hui voilà je ne l'aï pas non non
j'ai eu à recevoir demain alors la
dernière c'était c'est tellement bon
peut-être celle est qui est vraiment
il n'est qu'une vitesse celle de soi
même et là nous sommes vraiment au coeur
de notre voyage qui le jean marie le
bris jean marie le bris a fait une
expérience avec un cheval et une barque
et les îles nous avons voulu revenir sur
cette barque
ce cheval qui a tiré cette barque et les
et la barque n'oublions pas qu'elle se
trouve aujourd'hui au musée de l'air et
de l'espace
il nous avons donc créé un voyage
historique avec trois juments et une
roulotte qui vont depuis la plage où a
eu lieu cette expérimentation en
bretagne jusqu'au musée de l'air et de
l'espace et dans toutes les villes qui
ont un lien avec l'histoire de
l'aviation civile et complète notamment
celle de bois d'arcy qui va compléter
par la suite
là on à bannalec on a encore ploemeur et
puis j'en ai d'autres que je veux dire
que je vais compléter parce qu'il faut
les mettre par dix prochaines villes
étapes votre prochaine escale alors je
vais aller à buc sur la grande fête qui
aura lieu samedi prochain bucs sur les
pas de blériot et après évidemment nous
avons encore du temps à offrir à des
villes qui souhaiteraient une recevoir à
des écoles qui souhaiteraient nous
recevoir et nous allons aller encore sur
les pas de l'aviation avant de rejoindre
le salon international du bourget puis
le musée de l'air et de l'espoir et le
final ce sera où l'arrivée on revient au
point de départ et on va revenir à
plonévez porzay le 20 septembre
il nous célébrerons évidemment la
journée nationale du refus de l'échec
scolaire
alors juste pour conclure un clin d'oeil
puisque vous parcourez la france avec
cette roulotte nous sommes allés
demander à quelques saint-quentinois
quelques yvelinois si cette vie en
roulotte les faisait rêver l'avion doit
tout si ce résultat
ça me fait rêver oui bien évidemment
parce que bah c'est l'enfance et se
promener sur les routes c'est un peu
aussi les gens du voyage ce rouleau de
salaire koulou franchement oui comment
il s'agit des origines gitanes donc ça
me fait pas peur on veut une vie plus
saine
ou avec un rythme de vie plus plus leur
sueur dans une roulotte c'est à dire
qu'on a un cheval en même temps et donc
c'est un petit peu un retour aux sources
moi je suis en plus en hlm alors je
pense que la roulotte ce serait une
forme de liberté je pense moi je compte
faire le tour du monde donc ouais ça
peut être moins d'hébergement
intéressant si on me bouger voire le
monde
peut-être pas pour la vie mais d'être
une ou deux semaines mais pourquoi pas
les roulottes à l'ancienne quoi avec les
chevaux de st one ont quand même pas non
j'aime bien mon petit confort quand même
l'espace tous les iphones et les
appareils ménagers tout ça non dans
l'aventuré c'est bien mais c'est trop
tard pour moi des chevaux même
quelques-uns qui seraient prêts à vivre
en roulant trains si vous avez de la
place pour les accompagner pourquoi pas
s'ils peuvent venir avec vous puisque
vous parcourez donc le grand ouest jusqu
au milieu de cet été à travers la france
pour promouvoir l'aviation merci d'être
venu clémence de villecourt sur ce
plateau vous fait actuellement escale à
bois d'arcy et puis vous serez dans le
prochains jours a bu